all right
hello
Professor just wanted to give you an
early warning that some people may start
leaving at around six because of class
yeah well that's fine I'm not going to
beat great till seven anyways well we
might as well get started
thank you
this few people have an obvious
preference for the right side of the
lecture hall right here I guess it's
closer to the food eh
all right
so you're here to hear about psychology
as a career
so I'm going to talk to you a little bit
about careers in general
and then I'll talk to you about
psychology in general
so the first thing
you might want to consider
is that a career and job are different
job is something that you do from if
you're lucky I suppose from nine to five
and it's a job it's something where
someone else tells you what to do
and then you do it
and you're done
and usually it's fairly similar from day
to day and the disadvantage to that is
that someone else tells you what to do
and it's the same from day to day and
those are also its advantages
because if someone else is telling you
what to do then you don't have to figure
it out
and if you work from nine to five then
at five you're done
if you have a career then you're never
done it
and so one of the things that you want
to give some consideration to when
you're planning your career is how do
you learn to tolerate
never being done
I think
I went to graduate school in 1985 and I
think the first time I was caught up
might be this year
but maybe it happened five years ago
once or twice too so it took me
it's 30 years to catch up so I was
behind for 30 years and that's
um
it's hard on your nerves
so you have to accustom yourself to the
fact that no matter how much you work
you're it's not enough
and maybe you're starting to accustom
yourself to that in University but
the thing about universities it's
different from the rest of your life is
that although you already are faced with
the problem that there's way more to
learn than you're ever going to be able
to manage the only person that you're
responsible to at the moment
fundamentally
apart from your parents to some limited
degree is yourself
whereas once you start developing your
career
you're going to be responsible for a
larger larger larger number of people
and some of them will depend on you for
four actions that well if you're a
clinical psychologist sometimes that
their lives depend on so
your responsibility level
continues to climb as far as I'm
concerned that's a really good thing
people tend to take the responsibilities
of a burden but and I suppose that's
true but what they don't realize is that
human beings are like sled dogs or
attack mules who are not happy generally
speaking unless
unless we're
shoulders and burden or carrying a load
I guess it's part of being a social
animal
so it's actually good you have the
opportunity to
shoulder responsibility because it helps
you
tolerate living with yourself
you have to be worth something in order
to
really
tolerate the conditions of your
existence and so you ought to pick up
something heavy and carry it because
then
that helps you develop some respect for
yourself and also for other people and
that's a big deal but
that's worth more than anything that
anything else that will possibly be able
to find
now
how many of you are in your first year
put up your hands so I can see because I
need to know who I'm talking to Okay and
second
third
yeah and fourth here
so most of you in third and fourth year
all right so so you're thinking pretty
hard about what to do so well we'll
start with the fourth fourth year
students for those of you who want to
apply to graduate school which is of
course I suppose what you're going to do
most of you if you want to pursue
psychology as a career you better have
AIDS
because if you don't have AIDS it's
going to be rough
it might be rough even if you do have
80s but it's unbelievably competitive
especially Clinical Psychology and it's
increasingly the case and this isn't
such good news for those of you in your
third and fourth year but The Graduate
Admissions committees and universities
are starting to look before your last
two years they're really only supposed
to look at your last two years because
everyone knows that big students it's
reasonable to allow incoming University
students a year or two to screw their
heads on straight before you start
determining whether their performance is
actually an indication of their ability
so generally graduate committees are
only supposed to look at the last two
years but it's getting competitive
enough so that they're looking farther
back anyways Clinical Psychology
requires A's
um and then of course yes as we both you
know you have to take the graduate
record exam
um
there's two of them there's the standard
drugs which examine and there's the
psychology specialty Drive regressions
and most many universities don't require
the psychology graduate record exam I
would strongly remember I would strongly
recommend that all of you take it it's
your friend
if you're a psychology student from the
University of Toronto and you've done
reasonably well the problem probability
is high will just ace it because it
tasks knowledge that you've acquired as
a psychology student whereas the GRE the
general GRE tests more general knowledge
including mathematical arithmetic and
mathematical knowledge and that's not as
easy to acquire but but site students at
the OT Ace the psychology graduate
record exam fairly frequently so even if
the University
or universities that you're applying to
don't require it you might as well take
it and send it to them because if you
have the Stellar 97th percentile then
you know why not include the information
in your package
so if you score less than 80th
percentile on the verbal portion of the
general GRE I would strongly recommend
that you don't consider psychology as a
career because it's unbelievably writing
intensive and it'll grind you into the
right of the into the ground some people
are pretty smart mathematically and
analytically so when they write the GRE
they do well um they do better on the
non-verbal parts and I've had students
like that who are really
powerful intellectually but more
non-verbally and God give her greatest
statistics and they could be really good
analytical thinkers but the writing just
killed them you have to write all the
time as an academic psychologist and you
have to be very verbal as a clinical
psychologist and so if you're not up in
uh I would say top 15th percentile of
the people who are taking the Gres it's
going to be a real grind for you you
should think about that very seriously
because it's the writing is the most
difficult part of psychology as an
academic career and if you're not a
fluent writer you're going to have one
miserable time you're going to drag your
way through graduate school and you're
not going to be productive because
writing ability actually determines
research productivity more than anything
else and if you're not productive you
won't do well in the job market and so
it's do something else
there's no sense of setting yourself up
for you know a six-year grind and then a
dismal outcome
so students who aren't as
who are more intellectually powerful on
the non-verbal sections of the GRE are
often pretty good at designing
experiments and they can often learn how
to analyze the data too and that's great
but
what what causes graduate students to
stumble is writing up the papers
and so I often have students who prove
maybe you know completed 10 or 11
studies which is not plenty to finish
their doctor and to publish you know
several papers but they just can't write
them up
and so then they they languish because
no one else is going to do it so
if you're if you're verbally oriented
that's a good thing
don't be thinking that you get the pick
where you go to graduate school because
you don't and if you think that you get
to pick where you're going from graduate
school unless you're a straight 4.0
student with 99 percent of the ureas
then you're setting yourself up for
disappointment because
it's so competitive that what you do is
you apply to every bloody place you have
half a chance of getting into including
places that you think you'd never go
I think Lakehead for example has a
clinical program now I've got nothing
against Lake Tech by the way and small
universities have real advantages
sometimes because you're you're less
Anonymous in small universities but you
might think oh I'd never go latex well
you might be also thinking then that
you'll never go to clinical graduate
school because that could easily be the
only place that you'll get in so what
you do especially if you want to go to
clinical graduate school is you apply to
every single place that you can in
Canada whether you think you go there or
not you can always say no if they accept
you but if it's one you know maybe maybe
it'll turn out that one place accepts
you and that's a place you didn't think
you want to go well there's a big
difference between being in a clinical
graduate school but not really in it
it's the difference between zero and one
and so if you go off to Lake Avenue and
come up with the clinical PhD then
you're a clinical psychologist
so who the hell cares if you have to
spend five years you know in somewhere
that isn't
a trendy Urban setting you're going to
be sitting in a box most of the time
anyway it's made out of cinder blocks
doing your experiments and most of your
life they'll be the social life with
graduate students anyway so it's not
like you're going to be missing anything
one thing you might want to do if you're
fortunate enough to get accepted and
you're not sure whether you want to go
is to go talk to whoever's going to be
your supervisor because more than
anything else you ever do in your life I
would say if you go to graduate school
you're an apprentice to a supervisor
you're not a member of a department so
your relationship with your supervisor
basically determines when their graduate
school works for you or not so you want
to find out
ahead of time if possible whether the
person who wants to work with you is
someone who
that who's who you're who you think you
can get along with
what they're working on is less critical
I think because none of you know what
you want to do research on you might
think you do but you don't know enough
to know so I would also strongly suggest
that when you write your applications
for graduate school you make them
personal tell them tell the people who
you're writing to who you are
but don't specify a research interest
too closely because hardly anyone is
doing that research and why give people
an excuse not to take you
they're looking for an excuse not to
take you anyway so if I'm looking for
graduate students I have a staff of 100
applications or maybe 150. if I get rid
of 75 of those so fast that they might
as well might as well have not even
applied they're just gone usually what I
do is I make a spreadsheet I put in in
grades and the GRE scores and I code the
letters of reference and I sum across
and I rank order them and I knock off
the bottom 50 percent and everyone else
does that too even though they might not
do it in such a
quantitative way they should because
that's the most
efficient and accurate way of doing it
but everyone else who looks at that pile
of resumes is going to do the same thing
so
so you're already 50 of the people who
apply well they weren't going to get in
and likely anyways that's already a
tough you don't want also to have a
statement of interest that says well I
want to you know look at left
hemispheric language specialization for
second language Learners who are
children it's like there's probably one
person in North America studying that
and so anyone else who might be
interested in your application because
of your qualifications because it's
going to look at that and say oh they
don't want to work with me and then
you're a deal you can say what you've
worked on or being interested in
but what you should do and I'm not
asking you to falsify your letter of
intent because that's foolish but what I
would babe you to consider is that
you don't know that much about
psychology and
what you do when you specialize as a
graduate student is you start to develop
it's in a sense you narrow right because
you start to develop a lot of knowledge
about one specific topic but as you
narrow there comes a time when you start
to broaden out again because you get
into the single topic deeply enough so
you start starting to have you start you
have to consider the contextual issues
that surround that topic so for example
if you are say you're interested
neuroscientist but you end up studying
language developments well at some point
you're going to run into the brain
right because language development
depends on the brain and so
psychology in a sense it's a
metamorphous field and there's entry
points and all the entry points are
narrow but once you pass through the
narrow entry point you're in the field
and so it doesn't matter that much
specifically what you'll be doing your
work on for your master's degree in
particular because you don't know enough
to specify that at all and you'll be if
you're fortunate your supervisor will
basically tell you what to do for your
master's degree it only takes a year
right well it takes you two months just
to clue in when you first start a new
program and then you're already a
quarter of the way through the first
semester somebody pretty much pretty
much has to hand you a project and you
have to walk through it and so what it's
about is it really is important as the
fact that it's at hand and you've done
it I I'm not saying as well but what
you're interested in doesn't matter it
matters an awful lot but you don't want
to prematurely and narrowly specify your
domain of interest when what you're
relying on is information that's not all
that reliable and you're not an experts
enough in Psychology really to make the
determinive decision about what it is
that you're going to study I've ended up
studying all sorts of things I never
thought I would study things I didn't
think were worth studying that turned
out to be wrong over plenty we're
studying and they turned out to be
necessary
so
um learn your bloody staff so you should
be a wizard with SPSS or some other or
some other computer programmer from an
economic perspective there's nothing
that you'll learn as a psychology
graduate student that's more valuable
than statistics if you can use
statistics
they're all sorts of things open up to
you not not only experimental work and
you have to be a statistical expert
really to be a good scientist but
cross-disciplinary collaboration because
most other social sciences don't have
near the statistical expertise that
psychologists do Consulting for
businesses there's there's all sorts of
value in doing statistics and
understanding them so for those of you
who are in your earlier years don't shy
away from statistics especially the more
practical end of it which would be the
computer you know the PC or Mac programs
I would say PC generally PC programs
that enable you to do statistics you
should get good at that find someone who
will teach you how to do statistics
statistics is actually extremely
interesting once you start looking at
your
at yours it's a lot like gambling
and I mean that technically you know if
you pull a slot machine's arm there
isn't much of a chance that you're going
to get a good outcome but there's some
chance and so it's exciting the payoff
is variable reinforcement and research
is like that and statistics are exactly
like that because maybe you've spent six
months putting together a data set and
you arrange the variables in the SPSS
statistical machine so to speak when you
pull the handle and now you just learn
whether you wasted your time for six
months or you hit the jackpot so it's
actually pretty exciting it's different
when you're doing a class or working on
someone else's data set because what the
hell do you care but when you've got
when you've got something in the game
it's an entirely different process I
should also tell you that statistics is
not arithmetic and it's not mathematics
it's more like surgery and it's a moral
Endeavor which is funny you wouldn't
think that about a statistic but it is
immoral Endeavor because there aren't
any real rules for doing it a data set
is an amorphous and vague entity and the
write the information in it and your job
is to carve off the garbage and to keep
and to pull out the information that
requires it doesn't require the
automatic application of a set of
statistical rules that just won't work
at all your job is to figure out where
the truth is embedded in this messy
thing that you just produced that's
that's the typical study because most
studies they're complete disasters and
you never learn how to do them right
until you've already done it
depends on how skillful you are at using
the statistical tools and how carefully
you make your decisions ethically while
you're attacking the data set because
for example
it's going to be pretty damn highly
motivated to come up with something
where p is less than 0.05 right because
otherwise it's not technically
publishable even though that's a rather
foolish criteria but that's still the
point so if you put six months into
study and you know you have to decide
where the outliers are and where the
mess is and who to throw out and what to
concentrate on there's the little career
gamble at the back of your mind it's
going to be pushing pretty hard in the
direction of playing with the data in a
ways it makes what you want to come out
of it and you can bet that forty percent
of public studies science studies at
least are of absolutely no utility
whatsoever because the way they were
produced was biased by the fact that the
person who wrote them wanted to publish
the study and so that's a terrible thing
because it works the whole field but
it's even worse if you happen to be the
person that's doing it because you'll
fool yourself yourself and to discover
it's something that isn't there then
you'll convince yourself that it is
there then you'll spend the next 15
years chasing something that doesn't
exist in trying to prove to yourself and
others that it's real and that accounts
for a big chunk of what passes for
psychology researches it's a scandal in
some ways and the journals are
changing the way they accept papers
right now because this happens so
frequently so one of the things you want
to do if you want to be an academic
psychologist but you want to be a
scientist as a careers you better hit
your
your your your you have to decide what
it is that you're doing
and one thing that you might be doing is
building a career which is a social
Enterprise it's a primate dominance
hierarchy Enterprise and it it means
that what you're focusing on is climbing
up a private dominance hierarchy that's
not the same thing as trying to pursue
truth in science those are completely
different things if you pursue truth in
science you might also generate a career
if you've generated a career you might
also pursue truth in science but the
probability is relatively low now I
would suggest that you pursue truth in
science and the reason for that is
well first of all you won't get corrupt
and secondly you won't corrupt other
people but perhaps more importantly from
an existential perspective 20 years down
the road you won't look back at your
life and be disgusted by the whole thing
and cynical and not able to teach her to
talk to students or to be a good
graduate advisor because you're sick and
tired of the whole business
so and that's exactly what happened to
people who do things in a corrupt manner
they think it's cynical and why the hell
wouldn't they they should be cynical
because they're the sorts of people that
you should be cynical about
so the other thing you should decide to
do is if you want to pursue experimental
psychology as a career do you actually
care about scientific truth because that
matter to you if the answer is no I
would say go into business and no no
it's not a joke there's nothing wrong
with going into business
is important it's not easy but if you
want if what you're after is this sort
of status that comes along with a
business career don't be an idiot and no
one's after being young you might as
well just go into business and do that
you're not going to make much money as a
as a experimental psychologist
so if you're after status and and the
sort of status that comes along with
business and the sort of productivity
and social relations that come along
with business just go into business
don't don't do it and don't Sidetrack
yourself off into something that's in a
sense a more Arcane Pursuit
so okay so do your stats and get good at
it and you know you might be resentful
about having to do it because a lot of
people who are sort of oriented towards
the humanistic end of psychology are
pretty irritated about statistics and I
was certainly one of those people
because it didn't come out to me but
if you can't hack it get a tutor and get
A's and take more stats courses than you
think you need because you'll need them
so and if you go into graduate school
and you're sort of
crippled in in terms of your ability to
approach statistics you'll pay a big
price for it you won't be able to
understand the papers don't be able to
do your own analysis stab news
Okay so
fly everywhere
now you might say well I can't afford to
apply everywhere because each
application is 150 or I don't know what
it is what is it now 100
150 that's silly that's not a cost it's
an investment and you need to
distinguish between costs and
Investments and if you get in what are
you thinking what do you think of
experimental PHP is worth let's say you
get an academic job when you think
that's work yes
economically
come on is it a hundred thousand dollars
is it 50 million dollars what do you
think it's worth
anybody
ballpark asking
seventy thousand a year
okay that's good for how many years
four years maybe yeah okay so that's 300
that's three million dollars right
what's your pension worth
another two
and you're underestimate you
underestimate the seller in the latter
part of the career so it's probably
seven million dollars something like
that okay so now you know what you're
you're aiming at you get that out you
get that acceptance letter in the mail
is worth seven million dollars if you
play it right and if you're a clinical
psychologist it's probably worth twice
that
so you're after a 14 million dollar
price you ask well why is it so
competitive well now you know that's why
it's so competitive lots of people would
like to have 14 million dollars
so it's hard to get it
so so then if you're applying and it's a
hundred dollars 150 dollars let's say
you go to one in ten chance or one in 20
chance of getting in at any given school
so let's see what would you pay for a
one in 20 chance of 14 million dollars
how how would you calculate that
right 14 million divided by 20. so you
pay about 700 000 or something like that
so you pay seven hundred thousand
dollars not a hundred
so let's have that because you're
skeptical about your chances of winning
fine so then you pay 350 000 well don't
bark at 200 it's a bargain
and and don't get too irritated about
the application process it's annoying
they're trying to annoy you
because if you get annoyed and quit then
you they won't have to look at your damn
application and that's the end of you so
take a big amount of time to do your
applications because they're really
important and do lots of them many as
you can if you can afford to think about
going to need to ask throw some
applications down there that's
especially true if you're a hot student
and you're a hot student if you've got
80 basically an a average and a GRE of
90. percentile or above people will be
interested in you and that means it
might be the scholarship to an American
School you won't have to pay the tuition
so and that might especially be the case
you know maybe what maybe that won't
happen to you at Harvard or don't go it
might but there's lots of State schools
down there that are excellent to make
research schools and maybe they'll pay
you to come down and study so not only
do you get your crack at 7 million or 14
million dollars but someone will give
you some money to help you get it so
that's a pretty good deal so don't Blaze
out on the bloody applications it's
really important
all right
so let now we'll go back to more General
things for a minute
so now we might want to talk about what
makes people successful
okay and you want to also think about
what success means right and what
success means I can give you a couple of
rules of thumb about that I mean the
first thing is if you want to be
successful
let's let's put that let's use a
different traits we can say well let's
say you want to have a good life
don't mean good in that it's happy and
easy or any of those things I mean sort
of good classic if you want to have a
platonically good life okay so how would
one go about doing that well the first
thing I would say is do what other
people do
unless you have a really good reason not
to so what do people what do human
beings do to have a good life they have
friends
they have a circle of friends some of
whom they can talk to
carefully about the important things so
you need that people have an intimate
relationship with someone that is stable
across time
why well without that you're kind of
chaotic and lost and plus you only have
half your brain because people are
terrible in the animals and we're highly
communicative and if you have a partner
that you can trust who's got your back
that you can talk to and plan with then
you're twice as wise as the person that
you're competing with because it's just
like you know why is there sexual
reproduction instead of
clonal reproduction why is that
you guys have taken by all the courses
it's pretty fundamental question what's
the answer to that
variation
that's part of it though right yeah I
mean
as a as a unit
if you've cloned yourself first of all
the parasite could be again in no time
clock apart from that
you got a bunch of strengths and a bunch
of weaknesses and they're kind of random
and then you'll pair up with someone who
has much strengths and lunch weaknesses
and their kind of random and hopefully
when you pair up
most of the places you're weak that
person will be strong and vice versa so
that makes you a much more a much more
properly solidified unit sometimes your
weakness is a match and that's where
you'll fight Non-Stop and so you know
that can be a problem but still you're a
lot better off with somebody and that's
especially true if you also want to have
children and you're foolish not to have
children I don't know you guys are under
here okay most of the women in here most
of you be under 25 so there's probably a
fair number of people who think you're
not going to have children you must
bloody well dispense with that foolish
idea right now because all that means is
that you just haven't you you're you've
been War that's one thing it means and
second it means you don't know who the
hell you are because my experience has
been that virtually I think this is
virtually without exception every woman
I've ever met whether they thought they
wanted children at the age of 21 or 22
or 23 or 24 if they were basically
mentally healthy they were desperate for
children by the time they were 30. and
that kicks in in about 28 and so expect
it because it's going to happen and you
might think well no it's it's not going
to happen to me well you can take that
if you want but I'm basically what I'm
telling you on my work I've done a lot
of work with really high achieving most
of these were female partners of senior
partners of big law firms and being a
senior partner of a big Law Firm that's
as hard as being a successful clinical
psychologist like you have to be at the
top of your class as an undergraduate
then you have to get into a really good
law school and you have to be really
good at that law school then you have to
go off an article and you have to be
kept as an articling student then
generally you're not because the loss
big law firms they'll pull in article of
students working staff and throw away
all the ones that don't make it so if
you make it well then you get to be an
associate and then you'll get rid of
both of those too and then if you're
really good at it you'll be a senior
partner and so that's tough and look and
if you're a female and you've done that
you're bloody well committed to your
career it doesn't matter
by the time you hit 28 to 30
and you're working 70 hours a week
you're going to be thinking what the
hell am I working 70 hours a week for
which is really by the way a good
question and your your attention is
going to turn to happy children as it
should and the way you solve that if
you're a female and you want a career is
a you have a partner who's got a clue
and can provide some support and B you
Outsource most of your domestic most of
the domestic responsibilities that go
along with the household you have to
have a man maybe you have to have a cook
you don't do any housework you pay
attention to your kids with a little bit
of time that you have and that'll work
daycare doesn't work your bloody Law
Firm isn't going to take care of your
children they're not going to set up a
daycare in your firm that doesn't work
anyways but Anatomy will work and so you
might as well be thinking about things
along that line because if you want to
have a career and you're smart and
you're hard working and you should have
a career and you want to have children
then you have to set up your life so
that you can do those two difficult
things without dreading yourself start
craving that or exhausting yourself or
destroy your relationship and that's
about the only way that I've seen so far
that it's possible to do that okay so
anyways back to that
back to Career okay so now we've already
established that what you're after is
worth a lot and it's hard to get and
it's hard to get because it's worth a
lot and there's lots of people chasing
it now the question is what can you do
to give yourself advantage
okay well what makes you
good for something
from a career perspective well one is IQ
well you're pretty much stuck with what
you've got you can maintain it by
exercising
it turns out physical exercising is the
best way to maintain your intelligence
across time it starts to plummet pretty
precipitously after you're about the age
of 24 and it's downhill to 70 and then
well after that things get worse so
exercise helps so if you keep yourself
in good physical condition that's going
to make a big difference I would also
say if you want to play a sharp game so
if you're going to be on the edge of
things competing with people who are
saying the top one percent talk you
better get your drug and alcohol use
under control because that compromise
you you better make sure that you're
sleeping is well regulated
and you better make sure that you eat
properly and those are they're they're
not small things they're fake things
because you do them every day and so I
would say you can start to look at
yourself now get up to saving time every
day start learning how to do that I
would say get up 8 or 7 30 because
that's when symbolized people get up
and the people you're competing went
through you're really good competing
with they're opening up to six and
they're working by seven and they'll
work you right into the ground because
the people who are at the top of their
discipline and that's basically what
you're talking about if you're talking
about doing something that requires PhD
level of Education as a career they're
not walking around okay so here's a
question
think about this for a minute so think
about your typical day
now think about this how much time do
you waste
and so you can Define waste any way you
want to wait to Define it but I would
say time is wasted when what you're
doing isn't what you plan to do
right you know what it feels like to
waste time you feel like a right I
don't know there's a feeling that it's a
feeling for me it's like a feeling like
I need to take a shower
I deviated from the appropriate path I
mean you know YouTube hell yeah
and that's not good it's okay so now
you've thought about that typical day
how much time do you waste all right so
let's find out
um
how many people waste more than half an
hour
is there anybody here who thinks they
don't waste half an hour
and if you do think that please do tell
me because you know maybe you're
efficient some people learn to be
efficient okay how many ways two hours
all right
how about three
okay how many think they waste less than
three hours
okay one person okay I'll come back to
you okay
four hours
five hours
Jesus you better wake up people okay so
we're gonna let's save five hours
because I won't embarrass you further so
let's get all that mathematics
what's your time worth
no no let's come on let's make it in
money that's what we use to to evaluate
value right what's your time no
wrong why is that wrong
that's minimum wage no no no no no no no
we're gonna we're gonna play capitalists
here it's not invaluable I'm not going
to pay you an infinite amount of money
to do anything okay so so we're just
we're just talking about economic value
that's all this has to be quantifier
we're going to quantify okay it's not 10
and a quarter why
because you have a future
Kenneth quarters what you're worth if
your time isn't if if what you do now is
to contributing to who you're going to
be in the future so it's more than that
how much is it
okay well let's look at it this way
let's say you you manage your career
goals and it's 10 years down the road
and you're making
the amount of money you should be making
so we've got a rule of thumb here a
while back the 75 000 75 000 a year so
that's about
six thousand dollars a month or about
fifteen hundred bucks a week and so
we'll assume 40 hours so that's about
forty five dollars an hour okay let's
assume that you're worth 35. because
you're still a baby you're not worth
that but but the time that you spend now
is an investment right so even though
you might not be being paid for it this
second you're banking what it's worth so
you'll be paid for it later so you can't
be thinking it's ten bucks so we'll say
we'll save 40 because it makes the math
easier so how much time do you wasting
today five hours that's what's five
times forty 200 times 5.
a thousand right let's multiply it by
seven because after all you're wasting
time on the weekends too so that's 1400
a week how many weeks in a month
four what's four times fourteen hundred
fifty six hundred so we'll say we'll say
five for the same Army
5 000 a month how many months in a year
you're wasting sixty thousand dollars a
year
right
so maybe you should stop doing that
I don't know sixty thousand dollars a
year is a lot
and there are people the people that
you'll be competing with they're not
going to be wasting that time or maybe
they're going to be wasting thirty
thousand dollars for fifteen thousand of
it but if you're wasting five dollars a
day you better get your act together
because you're gonna pay for that in a
big way it's a foolish waste of time now
IQ there isn't much you can do about it
we already said that you've been
exercised and maybe you can read and you
can read as broadly as you possibly can
so you should read every day that would
be helpful and maybe you should read
non-fiction especially if you want to be
a scientist
but maybe you can learn to work harder
and one rule of thumb for that is how
much time you waste now we could do a
little more in depth analysis of ways to
be done because I could also ask you I
have students who come and see me and
they say
well I don't seem to be doing very well
in this course and I said well how much
are you working on they said well I knew
the library six hours a day
and I think that's what I asked I asked
how much time you're spending you're
working on
because first of all you should be in
the library six hours a day that's just
completely insane because I don't know
anyone at all except for a very small
fraction of people who are extremely
disciplined and well put together who
can concentrate on difficult material
for six hours in a row you're lucky if
you can manage three like real work so
the first thing you do is half your time
in the library and then and then double
your discipline so so let's say we can
look at a typical hour that you're
working I might say well how hard are
you working during that hour to how hard
you'd be working if someone pulled out a
gun and said look if you don't work as
hard as you can for the next hour under
the shooting and then you might think
well I'm working about one tenth as hard
as I can right like that's what that's
about right
I bet you that's about right the reason
I use that figure is because I figured
out a long time ago that if you have a
given task to do and you sit for five or
ten minutes and you think how can I do
this ten times faster you can almost
always figure out how to do it 10 times
faster and and sometimes better and ten
times faster and that's also something
to really know because what you'll find
as you mature into your career is that
you'll be asked to do way more than is
humanly possible and the way that you
learn how to do that is you get way
faster than you think you could be and
just using the 10 dimes marker as a rule
of thumb is an excellent one you it's
remarkable how much you can do in a very
short period of time if you set yourself
up with that expectation
so and then when you remember what your
time is worth well then you might think
about forty dollars by the least
underestimate your time's actually worth
more than that because
you're young and so
every hour that you have now to shape
yourself pays off through the whole
course of your life you know like what I
do now doesn't affect what I did when I
was 20. but what you do now that you're
23 is going to affect you when you're my
age so your time is actually worth more
even though you can't get anybody to
actually paying for it at the moment so
so another thing might really think
about learning to do is to figure out
how to get efficient and you got to be
ruthless with yourself to be efficient
and you better be efficient because if
you're going to pursue a career
efficient people win and they don't just
win a little bit I don't know you know
you guys have probably learned that most
things in life are normally distributed
right
now
height well you should have learned that
if you're a psychology student and you
haven't learned that then there's really
something wrong because that's like the
basic that's the basic premise of
statistics so of most statistics anyway
so all right so you know maybe the
average man is five foot ten
and then there's a standard deviation
around that if maybe I don't know it's
probably something like six inches and
then 85 percent of men no 6
8 6 5 percent of men fall in that range
okay so and Heights like that weights
like that and intelligence is like that
most things are
distributed according to the normal
distribution but life outcomes aren't
they're distributed according to a
Pareto distribution
and that's a Freer distribution
so
um anybody know how much money Bill
Gates has
about
40 million so how much money did the top
10 richest man in the US have
300 billion something like that so
that's a thousand dollars for every
single person in the United States
this is more than the average family has
in savings so the top 40 men in the
United States have more money than all
the rest of the Americans have put
together in savings okay so the top
hundred richest men in the world have
more money than the bottom two billion
right so this is a Pareto distribution
you see the same thing with creative
production so let's say you're looking
at
PhD students and you want to know how
many Publications they have well the
median number is one
the median is the number that most
people have right it's not the means
it's if you've popped out the typical
PhD student tell them by the caller and
said how many Publications do you have
you say one and I'd say while you're not
getting retired one
because one of us that it doesn't count
it's more than zero
but it's only one more than zero okay so
then there's going to be the top one
percent
of PhD students way the hell out here
and they're going to have
20 papers but
graduates which is about as many as the
typical
associate professor
and those are the people you'll be
competing on the job market
so they published that being their PHD
for five years they'll publish four
papers a year
and they'll come out and they'll be
higher
and so just for the sake of comparison
the typical professor at a top rate
research institution is about 40 them in
North America publishes between three
and four papers a year so The Graduate
students that are Hot Prospects of the
job market and that makes it likely that
they'll get an academic job although not
certain are out producing
typical associate and assisted
professors at Idaho University and
there's hardly any of these people and
all of the science is done by these
people
so the rest of them
so all the people who aren't way out at
that tail end they're just keeping the
institutions running
so
what's the typical profit margin for a
typical Corporation year after year
approximately
well guess how much money do you get how
much kind of interest do you get when
you put your money in the bank
Max
two percent
okay so obviously a company would have
to make more than two percent or no one
would ever invest in one so it's got to
be more than two percent okay well it's
around five
five percent so a really efficient
company runs on a five percent margin
that means it spends 95 percent of its
time just exists okay everything is like
that most things spend almost all of
their time just existed
all of the power comes into talking how
do you put yourself in the top end well
it helps to be smart
but you guys whoever's going down here
oh yeah
okay
so if you want to put yourself up
at this end of the distribution
how do you do it
well I can give you an example of the
differences in people's productivity so
the castle
produced 65 000 pieces for
three a day for 65 years
okay and the median number of pieces of
art that people produce is zero
right so that's a huge difference but
almost all fields of creative production
are like
almost everyone does nothing and a few
people do everything
Okay so
Bach JS Bach he wrote so much music
that if you took all his manuscripts and
you just copied them for eight hours a
day of taking 40 years
and he was actually writing the music
not just copying it up so people can get
unbelievably productive
and
they're the ones who have discovered
careers
okay so what do you do to do that
well
can't be much above your intelligence
but you can learn to work and work
matters conscientiousness is a trade
is a big predictor of long-term life
success
the conscientious people that ordered me
which isn't quite as relevant and
industrious industrious people when they
put their mind to something they do it
there's no wasting time and the people I
know who are really successful and so
they're often taught
one tenth of one percent which is only
one in a thousand right so you guys are
already probably one in a hundred if you
look at your IQs and your work ethic so
one in ten of you is one in a thousand
so
people like that they don't waste any
time
and I really mean that they'll make five
minutes be productive they'll be more
than five minutes than most people do in
a week and that's not an exaggeration
because they've learned to be bloody
efficient they do not waste time so they
think how can I do things ten times
faster they think how can I do this one
thing so it does five things
simultaneous you know so I kill five
birds with one stone instead of two and
that way the maximal use of their time
and they discipline themselves enough so
that they're going to be a constant
battle with themselves about doing what
they should be doing they just bloody
well do it and that's why they can
produce they can produce at these levels
so they're really almost Beyond human
imagination
so discipline really matters so if
you're wasting time
and you want to pursue a difficult
career you better learn how to get that
under control the best way to do that as
far as I can tell is to pick something
that's difficult you know that that
you'd like to do that's difficult
something that's kind of Beyond you and
do it bang your head against it will
probably think in a couple of years of
like really hard work to mold yourself
into something that isn't utterly
useless and that's a there's a big
payoff associated with that and I think
that's something you can do merely by
wanting it and attending to it
and that if you do that well first of
all
you get discipline and that's really
useful that's why it doesn't matter so
much when what you studied when you
first go to graduate school what really
matters is that you study something and
you really study it hard
now when I went to graduate school I
went to graduate school at the hill we
had a great time I had a great social
life that we go we spent a lot of time
let's go into restaurants and going to
bars and playing softball at a blast but
all the people I went to drive to school
with they work like 10 hours a day and
they work like Mad Dogs and so that was
fine we were down there 10 hours then
they can go off and have fun but there
was no mocking about during the work
period and whether they were hungover or
not they going up and they did their
work
and so that's what you have to learn to
do and it makes your life for it
enjoyable and entertaining a lot less I
mean if you really want to waste five
hours a day that's 130 you're wasting
time if you live 90 years you wasted 30
years and if you waste 30 years you'd be
and you wonder why you aren't getting
anywhere as much
come on
that's pretty easy to figure
if you waste 30 years and why shouldn't
because you're just wasting your time so
it's best to really learn how to stop
doing that to be a terrible battle
especially for those of you who
procrastinate you know lost people like
that you really have to rewire yourself
and get that under control
so if you want to be successful at a
high competition career then that's what
you have to do
okay I'm going to stop for a minute and
ask and take questions and then I'll
tell you a little bit about what options
you have if you choose psychology as a
career what sort of things lay
themselves open to you so so if you have
any questions
Now's the Time to ask them
side of the career will help you get
into grad school none
grades and Gres
that's what matters the rest of us fluff
I mean if you hit see the thing is it's
a multiple threshold cutoff system eh so
first of all you have to have AIDS if
you don't you're out then if you have
A's you have to have certain GRE levels
and if you don't you're out if you have
certain grades and certain GRE levels
then you're in
then it's random factors that determine
whether or not you're going to get
chosen which is partly why you want to
maximize your probability of success by
applying to many many places because
let's say that you're a threshold
student okay I'm going to look over your
application well what's going to
determine whether I take you
do I need a student that'd be number one
do I have to fund me do you have funding
funding if you can get a shirt or insert
or um MRC funding as a graduate student
that helps a lot I mean if you're above
threshold or even sort of that threshold
and if you have funding it's really easy
for a professor to say yeah yeah thank
you you're not gonna you know eat up
Grant resources so that's really helpful
so you can apply for graduate
school fellowships you have to still
have the same level of attainment some
extracurricular activities can help with
that if you have a lot of experience and
you can write a decent research proposal
that would increase the probability that
you can get a fellowship so so
laboratory experience helps there lab
experience also helps when you get to
graduate school because you know what
the hell you're doing and you can get a
jump on it but it's not going to help
you get in much now if I'm looking at
two students who basically cross
thresholds the same way and one of them
has extra lab experience and maybe knows
some computer programming and has some
useful skills or as good statistically
well then I'll certainly prefer without
them but I won't even see the
applications unless those first two
things are Matt and I probably am not
even deciding that because usually what
happens when you apply is that there's a
committee of Administrators that does
the first pass and they don't even let
you through the
your application through the door to see
the professors unless you meet the
minimal criteria so you know students
are desperate to get the extra
experience that we give them into
graduate schools like a publication
would help
but they're hard to get so if you do a
like an honors research project for
example and it works well you can write
that but almost no one does that because
by the time you're done your damn
project and you've written up your
thesis you're only one-tenth of the way
to having it published and that's
something else to think about too if you
want to be an academic psychologist like
everything you ever do will be rejected
and not just a little bit either you
work for something on for six months
like or write your first research paper
and you'll send it out maybe not to
leave in a very good journal and you'll
get three reviews back and they'll say
this is the stupidest thing I've ever
seen and you might as well quit you know
and that's and you'll get those letters
throughout your whole career now now
then they'll say well
this doesn't suck as much as it could so
if you really work hard on it and you do
this part again and you address these 30
concerns then we'll be willing to look
at it again but don't get your hopes up
and that's when you go have a you know a
pint at the local bar because that's the
best news you're going to get this month
so that's another thing to think about
too
when you're when you're thinking about
whether this kind of career is for you
because if you're rather high and
negative emotion
okay you're going to get punched in the
stomach a lot and you've got to ask
yourself whether or not you can learn to
tolerate that it's just it's just a
function of the of the business because
it's hard to get published you know the
rejection rate in the journal is 95 to
99 which is worse than your application
you know your chances of getting
accepted to a given graduate school so
just looking for reasons not to publish
your damn paper and it can be because
there's a mistake and it might be
because it's too good you know and it
scares people are there political
reasons or whatever but there's a lot of
rejection and that's true for most
careers so you have to be used to that
but in Academia I think in some ways it
works because you're always trying to
publish them the answer is always we
don't want your stupid paper we've got
100 other ones so
you do some clinical work as well as
your research and teaching at your key
okay
um why you will why one might
um
want to work with the professor why
clinical psychologists might choose to
work as a professor rather than
full-time clinical work well okay well
so one of the answers to that is why you
would ever want to be a professor okay
so here is why you might want to be a
professor one of the things you might
watch about yourself you want to see
when you're talking with other people
does your is your tendency to turn a
conversation to ideas
that means you're open that's a trade
openness if you tend to turn the
conversation to ideas then you're
you're in your intellectual fundamental
you're open
that's a good reason to be a professor
you like ideas
your friends is what you use most of the
time just talk about people or maybe
what you did last night or those are
fine things those are probably probably
means more than you're extroverted or
maybe you talk about relationships and
that means more that you're agreeable
that's not really the kind of
temperament that is suited for an
intellectual Pursuit because it's about
ideas fundamental and then you also have
to ask yourself would you like to teach
and teaching is teaching is brutal for
people who don't like it I mean you know
you have professors like this they stand
in front of the board they look down
they Mumble they're so bloody terrified
of the students they won't even look at
them and everyone there is like checking
Facebook it's awful so you know if
you're if you don't like to engage an
audience you're going to spend the most
exhausting part of your career teaching
because teaching teaching writing is
very exhausting so is doing clinical
work but right out there is teaching
because a lecture is a performance it
takes a tremendous amount of energy
you know unless you do it by Road pins
and it's boring but otherwise
it's like spontaneous Jazz for 90
minutes it's very tiring and when I
teach three courses in the spring I just
bloody wipe down by it by March and I've
got a lot of energy so you'll you also
have to decide if you want that and then
you have to decide do you like mentoring
students graduate students I really like
lecturing and I really like
ideas and I really like mentoring
graduate students so being a university
Professor is perfect for me and I got
used to being rejected the papers being
rejected I learned how to deal with that
in about three or four years I used to
just piss me off I'd be mad for like
three months after I go to rejection
letter you know I get the envelope and I
wouldn't even want to open it because
you know what it says it says up yours
you don't want to see that you know but
you learn not to take that personally
because it's not personal they don't
hate you they just hate everybody
so if you can learn to tolerate it
that's good now you asked me why you
would be a clinical psychologist as well
as a professor well
that depends to some degree on what kind
of breadth of
experience you're inclined towards so
for me life is better if I'm doing a lot
of different things and so being
clinician I do I'm a clinician I do
Consulting with businesses
I'm a professor
and I run a little testing company that
that evaluates employees and I have
other
I have other jobs I think I have seven
jobs actually at one point it fluctuates
between five and seven and the reason I
do that is because I learned how to
do things flat out all the time it turns
out I'm kind of wired for that so it's
better I
for me that's better
um I love doing clinical work
it's sometimes people wonder too how you
can do it because you say well people
bring me their problems to you all the
time right
but it isn't like that because
social work is like that I think I think
you're insane to be a social worker if
any of you are thinking about that I
think of all the jobs that will just
Hammer you to death over a five-year
period that and teaching junior high
school kids
because see the thing about being a
clinical psychologist is the people
coming to you have problems but they
don't want to have them that's why
they're coming to see you and so what
you're doing isn't dealing with people
who have problems you're dealing with
people who want to get rid of their
problems and so the trajectory is uphill
and it doesn't really matter how bad the
current situation is if there's hope in
the future right because
your oriented toward the future so if
you're working with your clients and
they want to have better lives and
you're helping them do that
that's
it's a fine thing to do it's a great
thing to be able to do
perhaps
a lot of Clinical Psychology
and clinician work because grad programs
hear them that way
well it depends on the grad program so
there's two kinds of there's actually
three kinds of clinical graduate
programs there is the graduate programs
that are characteristic of large
research institutions so say like McGill
and McGill is mostly a scientific
institution with a side bar of clinical
training and most research institutions
are like that and so most APA approved
that's how it used to be anyways APA
approved American Psychological
Association approved programs tend to be
research oriented
and they provide clinical training so
what they expect of you if you're a
student there is to be a scientist and
to be trained as a clinician now there
are also side e programs they're more
common in the U.S they'll charge about
forty thousand dollars a year and will
train you basically just as a clinician
and then there are clinical programs
that aren't in major research
institutions but are still in public
universities where most of the emphasis
is on clinical training and less is on
experimental work and they're usually
not designed to they're not geared at
producing academics who could train
clinical psychologists which is what the
big research universities are for and
yeah often when you go there like we
deal
if you were a successful clinical
student you became a professor
it was the unsuccessful clinical
students who became clinical
psychologists and you know you could say
well that's because that was all they
could do well that's a cynical way of
looking at it but in some ways it's true
because to be a professor at a research
institute like the uot and a clinical
psychologist you have to be able to be a
scientist and and to do everything
that's associated with that
so
it's a it's a it's a good option if you
can pull it off because you have all the
stability that goes along with being in
a university plus you have old
undergraduates and you know if you like
undergraduates
if you don't like undergraduates you
really don't like people you know
because I mean undergraduates they're
all shiny and clean and you know they're
all happy about their Futures and
they're all probably going to be
reasonably successful man if you can't
deal with undergraduates you might as
well dig an old client into it because
that's about as good as it gets among
human beings
you know soul
anyway so if you're a professor you get
to stay in that you know you and then
you know I do my clinical work and my
Consulting work as well so it's sort of
like the best of both worlds but there's
a lot of there's a lot of preparation
that goes into doing all those things so
for example
you have to do I think I have to do 2
000 hours of supervised practice when I
came back to Ontario
after I was in Massachusetts even though
I was licensed in Massachusetts so
there's it takes quite a bit of work to
keep here
because just after you get your clinical
PhD you're not a psychologist yet you
have to do another 2 000 hours of
supervised practice and to do that as
well as to do what you need to do in
order to pursue an academic career means
you know you're you better be efficient
so other questions
I've heard from a lot of people who
should look for supervisors who are
working on areas that you're interested
in yeah if you have straight A's and 98
algories do whatever you want
if you don't apply everywhere and I
would say even if you do apply
everywhere you can always say no
you know what is what a delightful deal
you apply to 40 places let's say or 30
places formed realistically and four
people give you an offer and you fly out
there and they try to tell you how
wonderful you are and try to get you to
come and you get to say no to three of
them and pick the best one that's a deal
so that's what you want to set yourself
up for
so and you know if you if you really
know what you want which is doubtful but
maybe you do because sometimes people do
and you can specify who you'd like to
work with and they're interested in you
can Target that carefully hey more power
to you but that's very rare and for most
people it's it's it's not a good
strategy look I've had lots of students
ask me about how to get into well let's
say specifically clinical graduate
school and I say applied in lots of
places then they don't they apply them
for
and they're threshold students and they
don't get in well that's pretty rough
you know they languish for years
sometimes two years as they try again
usually by the second year of not
getting in then they listen and quiet 30
places and then they get in and then
they say geez you know if I would have
done that the first year
I would have been you know
waiting at the local bar for two years
while I was trying to get into graduate
school so if if if you're 100 credible
and you've got an inside track
you know there's normal rules don't
apply to you and that's fine but
it's a numbers game and with most things
that are low profitability the way you
maximize your Champion success is to do
it a lot
Chris you know if you have a 1 in 10
chance of getting in somewhere and you
apply to 20 places
you know you're probably going to get
into two
you fly to 80 places
you might get unlucky and get into none
so
not here not at St George Scarborough
possibly they're working on it but it's
hard to set up a political program you
need a lot of clinical faculty and you
need to be tied in with hospitals it's a
multi-year process so not in a
foreseeable future but your Catholic
clinical program Ryerson has a clinical
program
is there a clinical program at Louisiana
child clinical offense oh yeah okay yeah
yeah other questions yeah
not at all it's easier like if you're
it's easier to get into graduate school
if it's not clinical
that doesn't mean it's easy
it's still hard but it's not impossible
like it is with clinical
um the problem with that is is that
although it's
you know it's modern
difficult they are even extremely
difficult to get into an experimental
program period the problem is is that
with the difficulty comes a little later
the difficulty then becomes getting a
job
because it's just as hard to get a job
as a social psychologist
as it is to get a job as any other I
mean an academic job as any other kind
of psychologist so the entry area for
graduate school is less but they entered
barrier into the job Mark might even be
higher
so and so what you have to do is all
you're doing this is something to
remember
you are not going to graduate school for
the classes what you want to do is
barely pass
because otherwise you're working too
much on the classes
because the classes are useless they're
you're not going to learn a damn thing
and all they do is take you away from
what you should be doing and what you
should be doing is publishing papers
because that's all that matters if you
publish enough papers you'll get a job
assuming that you know you're not
flawed in some remarkably obvious other
way so so that you want to remember that
when you go to graduate school so if you
pass a graduate course you get an A
that's how graduate courses work
anything other than the name is a
failure
so there's a bunch of complicated
reasons for that
to pass a graduate class you have to do
a decent job they're easier than
undergraduate classes
but they don't matter you have to pass
them because if you don't want to take
you on the program but if you pass them
it's irrelevant no one cares no one's
ever going to look at your bloody
gravity
transcript for grades
except for maybe different you know the
fellowship granting agency so that's the
one exception but if you pass the course
you get an A anyways the reason you get
A's if you pass the courses because if
you don't get a
let's say I give 30 of my graduate
students bees then they don't get
graduate fellowships because the
graduate Fellowship programs will only
give graduate fellowships to students
who have AIDS so the way the university
suggests to that is you get A's if you
pass otherwise you fail
so you have to work hard enough to
graduate course to pass
having done that then you have to work
really hard to get your damn
because that's that's where the lead
German how hot a prospect you are when
you graduate and you want to be
in social psychology each year
there's going to be five or six
graduates in North America who everyone
wants so they're the guys on the
tail here and then there's everyone else
and everyone else has a hell of a time
those top five students or six students
they have their pick of jobs that's
where you want to be and to do that
you need to publish the bar keeps going
up because
you know it's hard to publish because
people tell you no computers have made
the process more straightforward
right it's the journals are right at
your fingertips you don't have to spend
the day looking for each Journal like
you did when I was a graduate student
and then the journal wouldn't be there
anyways because you can get them
instantly and you can do your stats on
your laptop whereas I had to use a
Mainframe in 1985 and but I tell you the
manual for that name frame
and I'd like to use the computer you
know anything about statistics the
manual was as long as this table was one
book on
metal rods that long it's like to do in
Anova was a nightmare now you just quick
it's done so so some of the barriers to
publication number have followed but the
consequence of that is to talk students
publish form says it already easier you
just
you have to spend exactly the same
amount of time as you would have before
except now you the output's higher but
you're gonna you're gonna need
10 to 12 Publications and a couple of
book chapters most of those should be
first offered you should be the first
author on five or six of those papers
and two of them should be in good
insurance and then you're set but I'll
tell you to get that you better be run
it because it's it's it's not hit by
very many students
and the problem with graduate school and
this is something else to understand
people will leave you alone in graduate
school and what that means is you can
float around vaguely for five years
graduate with one publication and
disappear
so it's dangerous graduate schools
dangerous that way because no one will
be on your case to make sure that you're
one of the top students so you have lots
of freedom but you've got to also ask
yourself you know do you want freedom
and can tolerate it so do you want it
well people float and drift if they have
too much freedom and then can you
tolerate the questionnaire is can you
discipline yourself enough to be
successful without someone basically you
know watching your vid hitting you in
the back of the head and and that's a
tough question because
it's not easy to become that future
oriented and that discipline so
so that's the Social Security the other
thing I've also mentioned about social
psychology is learn your psychometrics
because most of social psychology is
nonsense
and there's a reason for that
the reason is is that social
psychologists don't know measurement
very well and they're starting to clamp
down but all the journals have adopted a
new code of ethics for Publications and
the reason they've done it is because so
much of what particularly was published
in social psychology is simply not true
so learn your psychometrics and learn
your statistics and that'll really do
you well in Social psych there's lots of
things to be discovered in social
psychology but you have to be
hard-headed and not be after your career
so
I don't necessarily see how it makes
sense for clinicians to be more focused
on publishing when they're in graduate
schools and their classes because it
doesn't have to be trained with them for
their job attention
exactly how many good what percentage of
classes have you taken in the last year
that were good
um
Maybe
okay so there you go it's worse than
graduate school
so 90 of the timing classes will be a
waste if you want to learn to be a
clinician you could start now
read Carl Rogers read Abraham Maslow we
call you read Satan Freud like there's
lots of great clinicians read them read
them that'll help a lot does that mean
that the system is flawed because yes so
watch all systems are flawed most of
them are like really flawed systems are
murderous if you're in a system and it's
not stopping you to death it's actually
working not too bad these people are
supposed to be smart
they are so why is
well I remember like earlier in the
lecture I thought talking about
businesses right I said businesses run
on a five percent profit margin that
means they spend that's an efficient
business because most businesses fail so
really well-run businesses produce five
percent profit year after year that
means they spend 95 percent of their
time
just existed
and that's how systems work systems spin
good systems and only 95 of their time
existed bad systems spend about 125 of
their time existed which means that not
only do they not produce anything of any
value they suck resources from other
things that are producing things of
value
and so it's really look it's really
important I know you're you're skeptical
about this but that's because you don't
know what you're talking about and you
should listen to me
most systems don't work
and a lot of them are murderous and so
if you go off to graduate school
because you don't listen no you're not
yeah well
that's what you think okay another
question
what would you recommend to take the GRE
EK
most people usually take say in the
summer before they start two o'clock
and that's probably about right because
I wouldn't push it too close to when you
applaud it because it's just the
application process is stressful and you
probably don't want to clutter those
things out too much
I would also say
people do a lot of study for the GRE
it's not that helpful
if you want like the one thing you can't
study for is the psychology of GRE
and the basketball agreed and
introductory testing
or two
but I wouldn't kill yourself studying
for the GRE because
it's not going to help that much
so partly because like the vocabulary
let's say
you've built up your vocabulary over
maybe twenty five thousand hours of
study just add another 100 hours to that
it's strong and
so
during the summer of any early fall and
then you probably have to apply for
November to January
so anyways back to your question
if you want to what you have to do with
University and this is what you have to
do in graduate school as well is what
the institution does is it opens up a
space of identity for you and the
identity is you're a graduate student
okay what does that mean
well it means any number of things it
means you can languish for five years if
you want but what it does mean is now
you have a stamp of approval on your
forehead and so you can sit around and
read and learn things
you don't have to worry about whether or
not you're useful because everyone has
said
by all possible measurement you appear
to be useful so that means you get to
have the luxury of educating yourself
now you go off to an institution and 90
of the courses won't be worthwhile just
like they are in every institution but
some of them will be really worthwhile
and so your job is to discriminate
between the things that are worthwhile
and the things that aren't and to really
focus on where you can get educated and
there's lots of places to get educated
so for example
you'll have Replacements and you'll have
clients and you'll learn like if that's
an opportunity right there to learn
because that'll be the real thing and
you'll need people who know what they're
talking about and you want to stick to
them like glue because they'll teach you
things but and you
it's okay that systems don't work very
well because they have to spend most of
their time just existing because they're
complicated things you know so
and the reason I use the business
example is because
businesses pay a big price for a
deficiency they just feels dive into the
ground and disappear and so if even a
business can only manage
five percent genuine productivity that
gives you a rule of thumb against which
you should
judge institutions in general
it's hard to make something work I mean
you look around the world most countries
don't work most governmental systems
don't work and a lot of them get so out
of control that they kill people
so what you hope for is you hope you can
get in somewhere that has possibility it
opens up a space for you to do what you
can do if you're disciplined and ready
to go and that's good enough and so the
classes a lot of classes they're not
going to be worthwhile that's okay you
put in as much effort as you need to
pass them and you bloody well pay
attention to the things outside of that
where you're actually learning
depends on the institution that you go
to like if you go to a side e program
which is just professional training they
won't care if you publish they're not
trying to produce people who are
scientists the idea with the Ada
programs is that you can't be a good
clinician unless you're a scientist and
there's some real truth in that and bad
clinicians really hurt people
like you can mess up someone's memory no
trouble if you're a foolish clinician
you could cause a lot of misery grief
because people especially confused and
vague people they'll open themselves up
to you and you can then whatever
bone-headed biases and lack of clarity
you bring to the situation has every
possibility of making things worse for
them so so the big research institutions
they want to train you to think
critically
and
and a critical thinker is someone who's
good at getting rid of what isn't
necessary and keeping what is
I mean often when you think of critical
things thinking you think of criticizing
things you know like this isn't good or
that that isn't the point the point is
to say well that's not as good as this
so I'll keep this and that isn't as good
as this it's what you do when you end in
the painting you get rid of what's not
perfect and keep the rest and that's
what you have to do when you go to get
educated as a graduate student I would
say if you want to be a clinician read
the great clinicians you'll learn more
from them than
than from anyone else except your
clients and with your clients
the best thing to do with them is listen
to them
and this is something that Carl Rogers
that's one good reason to read Carl
Rogers one thing about Carl Rogers is he
really figured out a list of people
and
people love to be listened to because
most people don't have anybody to talk
to and because they don't have anybody
to talk to they can't organize their
brains because the way people organize
their brains is by talking
well I've got this problem I don't know
what to do about it so he said well
what's what's the problem and he said oh
it might be this it might be that it
might be this maybe it's this it reminds
me of that it's like they're laying out
the situation on the table so you say
okay we keep telling me let's learn the
whole problem up and then they're afraid
of that because they don't want to lay
the whole problem out so you convince
them it's okay lay the whole problem
we'll worry about sorting it afterwards
so they made the whole problem out and
then they look at it and they think oh
well this isn't really the problem and
neither is this and this isn't the
problem and neither is not this is the
problem and then it sort of cut down the
size right that's about it you might say
well
you know what do you want to have happen
right so I'm not sure what I want to
have happened so they lay all that out
and then they push away what isn't
necessary now they have the problem now
they have what they would like is a
solution and then say okay well you know
what steps can we Institute little steps
that you would actually do
transform this problem into this
solution
and that's very entertaining it's very
useful for people and so one of the
things you can do right off the bat is a
junior clinician is listen to the person
and if you don't understand what they're
saying just ask them say no I don't I
didn't get that it's not clear or maybe
you say you just said that but 10
minutes ago you said this and they seem
to be opposites and I don't understand
how those two things can both be true
and by doing that you walk them through
the process like your brain is organized
at the highest level linguistically
and so if you walk through people
through a process of carefully
articulating their situation you it
organizes their brain and you can do
that as a as a pretty Junior clinicians
as long as you're
as long as you're listening
so
yes what would you say is like if the
biggest motivated
that's a good question
um
well I think there's there's two things
you need to be motivated
one is you need to have a clear
conception of what your life could be
like if it was really good
so I could say to you and this is oh by
the way here here's an exercise you guys
could do if you do this it will help you
a lot
you can go to this website
and there's four exercises there they're
writing exercises and if you do them by
the time you're done you'll be like
three times as efficient as you are now
it's hard
one exercise will ask you right
autobiography and the other another
exercise I'll ask you to do some
personality analysis to figure out what
your faults are and how you might
overcome them another one will ask you
to figure out what your virtues are and
how you can capitalize on them and then
the last one will ask you
to figure out here's what it asks you to
do basically it says so here's you want
to get yourself in the right state of
mind so here's the State of Mind imagine
that you were taking you were charged
with taking care of yourself okay so now
you're someone that you're supposed to
take care of I don't care what you think
of yourself because people are
ambivalent about themselves you know we
don't take care of themselves very well
I'm going to put that aside we're going
to show you you're going to take care of
yourself so you're going to figure out
what would be best for you not what you
want or what would make you happy or any
of those things but what would be best
for it so you need to have a vision of
that and you can ask yourself that
three to five years down the road if I
had
the best life I can have
what would that be like on this the
fourth exercise kind of steps you
through that it asks you to think about
people you admire and to think about
your friends and your family and your
career and the way you structure your
life day to day and you try to meditate
on what that would be like if it was
optimized
okay and then and then the exercise
steps you through
a process of clarifying that
okay so now that's your little vision of
Heaven
okay so now you've got that you know
what your life could be like if you were
living in proper okay now you need to do
the opposite of that which this program
by the way also asking you
everybody has a sense of how they can
fall apart
all you do is look at how you already
have fallen apart and then you multiply
that out
and you think about the people that you
see on the street or that you see who
you see in devastated marriages or who
have terrible relationships with their
family and you think okay what would my
life be like
if I really let it fall apart
and if you meditate on that property
that should really scare you
and it should scare you deeply
so you should think there's no way I'm
doing that I've got whatever
happens I'm not doing that so then
you've got your little Heaven you've got
your little help
and you know the difference between them
and then you can start to conceive of
your day-to-day life in relationship to
those two things
and you can decide
which one you want
if you do that properly
it's a deep process because
if your life really gets out of control
not only are you
miserable beyond comprehension but still
perfectly capable of making it worse
you're a little source of community
pathology and everywhere you go you make
it worse and that's how it really that
really is hell
and I would recommend that state I would
recommend that you stay as far away from
there as you possibly can
so you need to know those extremes
because those are like the extremes of
human existence and you need to know
that they exist and what they are for
you
and then you can construe Your Existence
in relationship to those two things and
that can help make you motivated
so
and it's it's good to do it as a
meditative process and thinking
meditatively is different than thinking
in a directed way because so here's a
meditative exercise you could try this
this is a very useful exercise
try this tomorrow morning if you do this
regularly it'll change your life but it
sees it it's a simple thing to do
technically sit on the edge of your bed
when you wake up
and ask yourself like you were asking
a friend
not someone you knew well but someone
you you have positive feelings towards
you 'd like for things to go well for
this person ask yourself what you could
do
to
make the day progress
in the best possible manner so you ask
yourself what you could do to do that
and then you ask yourself what you
actually would do
and you'll you'll get an answer the
actual dressed up from the depths of
your unconscious you'll say well if
there's things that I've been avoiding I
should you know chip away at those a
little bit maybe I do this little thing
without getting all resentful about it
and then tonight my life will be one
tenth of one percent better
just very much it's a good ambition for
someone who isn't very disciplined but
one tenth of one percent is a lot
you know in a thousand days at one tenth
of one percent with no compounding it's
100 better
so
those things can be motivated one of the
things one of the things I've learned
from my own research because I did a lot
of research into compellitarianism
because I was very interested in why
people were motivated to do terrible
things to other people
and the reason they're motivated to do
terrible things is because they let
their lives Fall Apart
and your life is hard your life is
basically tragic in its essence
so life is a difficult burden and if you
don't carry that burden properly it'll
make you resentful and then it'll make
you cruel
and so if you don't want to be resentful
and cruel especially if you know what
that means
then you'll do what you can to put
yourself together because then you'll be
a force for good rather than evil that's
a lot better
it's a lot better
there's almost no limit to how much
people can suffer
stunning to see which is also one of the
reasons I really like being a clinical
psychologist
I mean being a clinical psychologist
keeps you very much in touch with the
actuality of people's lives and that's
very
it's unbelievably useful and it's so
useful like I spend 20 25 hours a week
every week
helping people walk through their most
difficult problems you can't imagine
doing anything
more possibly useful for informing you
about how to straighten out your own
life
so
it's worth doing it seriously these
exercises locally we've been doing
research with this sweet exercises we
use them first in future offering one on
a group of students on the hill who were
academically struggling so they were on
academic probation but they're they're
smart right because you have to have an
idea however she get it to be open
but they were failing so we had to all
go through this program we used a
balanced control group it was a perfect
experimental design
we raised their grade point average 25
percent and dropped their drop away from
30 to zero it's a massive change now
we've been using the same program the
Future Part of this on a bit at a
business school in in Rotterdam we've
used it on two consecutive cohorts of
800 incoming students and we dropped
their drop off rate from 50 to 30
percent raise their grade point average
25 and I mean I've used the future
offering program regularly on on people
I know and also on clients it'll change
your life
so people very seldom sit down first of
all you have to think through who the
hell you are
right where you come from how did it
shaped you and that's a really useful
thing to do if you're going to be a
clinician it's like psychoanalysis right
it kind of gives you a sense of who you
are and then you also have to take some
time to think well what do you want from
your life like what sort of what sort of
creature do you want to meet as a human
being is an amazing thing
you know like we can be just the most
wretched creatures murderous and corrupt
beyond belief but the personalized their
act together is a like a force of Nature
and that's a lot better so you might
think well we want to be a force of
nature you know because you've got the
opportunity you guys you're smart you're
young I imagine you're you're healthy
and absolutely you can at least manage
University it's like what the hell are
you waiting for hammering yourself
together and see what you can do it's
worth it make your life
way better
on unimaginably
manifested one
it's a good thing to do so that's that's
I don't know any other way to be
motivated now
sorry I do a lot of other thing that's
used
as you step through your life you'll see
that there are certain things that sort
of call out to you you know that grab
your attention involuntarily
and that's a very interesting thing
because
people think that they're sort of the
Masters of their own destiny you know
that you own you people often will make
that argument about suicide for example
it's my body I can do what I want with
it it's like well no neither of those
things happen to be true and if you act
out you'll pay for it but there's
reasons it's not true it's not some
arbitrary idea it's that you're governed
by forces that you don't understand
those are the forces the psychoanalysts
again the fight is unconscious and
unconscious forces
are the things that make you interested
in things
you can't control that you know that if
you're reading some blood and boring
paper some other person might find that
the most thrilling thing in the world
you you can't even concentrate on it
you'd rather do the dishes or even if
you're thinking about the girlfriend you
have great age or something your mind
wanders you can't focus on this you say
well I have to focus on it because
there's a task tomorrow it's like you're
unconscious mind he doesn't care it's
like no we'll go vacuum that up the
carpenter you know or or clean out
underneath clean the dust bunnies out
from underneath the bed anything but
read this paper and then there'll be
another paper that's twice as difficult
and you're compelled by it you stick to
it like glue and then you'll remember it
right away and you think well why is
that why do you why is the one thing so
easy for you and the other thing so
difficult and even worse White Hand
eating Jews
that's a strange thing because you think
well a keyword in control you just say
well I'm going to be interested in this
paper and well good luck with that and
so if you deciding what you're
interested with well then you've got to
ask yourself
what the hell is it
and when you start asking yourself that
question that's when you start to become
a clinical psychologist
because that's a hell of a question so
anyways in terms of motivation one of
the things you can learn is to help is
how to follow those things that compel
you
and you have to be careful when you're
doing that because you also have to you
have to balance that with a certain
degree of honesty because if you're
dishonest and deceitful then you'll
corrupt the workings of your neural
mechanisms and then the light will be
shining for places you don't want it to
shine from
so if you're going to pursue the things
that compel you
which you can do which I think is a very
good thing to do that's a quest by the
way
you also have to straighten yourself
automatically because otherwise you'll
end up taking some some bad turns and
you can get ridiculously motivated if
you do that because you'll end up living
in a world where everything is so
interesting to you all the time that you
can hardly stand it
and you know that's
that's a good place to be
so
um I was just wondering whether a gap
year between your undergrad and grad
school would be like a little bit down
upon no
to some degree on what you do with it
but I think it's a good idea actually
you know and if you can if you can make
use of the time
and so you have to decide if
do you have something to do with during
that year that's productive and that
will further your development it'll make
you more mature that would be the best
thing to do so it doesn't actually
necessarily um
be beneficial directly to address book
about something that is productive
towards yourself like if you wanted to
do a specific thing before before your
graduate school whatever that thing is
doesn't necessarily have to be related
to it no no no and you know we remember
like anybody you want to work with is
going to be reasonably sensible
because why do you unless you want to
work with someone who isn't and anybody
who's reasonably six sensible is going
to think well you know this person's
young they should go kick around a
little bit
you know me one of the problems in place
like Universal Toronto for example is it
lost the students here live at home for
their whole undergraduate career it's
like well not some preparation for
graduate school
you know so if it will Foster your
Independence and make you more
disciplined and broaden your experience
no one with any sense is going to look
on that as anything positive
so
um
customer choice if I wanted to um
well if you're going to go to medical
school you probably pursue a career in
psychiatry
yeah and the difference between a
psychiatrist by the way the psychologist
is that well psychiatrist is an MD
psychiatrist can and does prescribe
drugs and there's nothing wrong with
that by the way if you're a clinical
psychologist and somebody comes to see
you and they're like suicidally
depressed what you tell them is well you
know we're not going to make a lot of
progress in the next two weeks so you
might want to think about taking some
antidepressants so if you've got enough
energy to put your life back together
you know you don't want to be
dogmatic about any of these things so so
drug therapies can be extremely useful
but generally if you if you take the
Medical Group you become a psychiatrist
psychologist
well you can't describe directly but
that doesn't really matter because
you'll learn enough about
pharmacotherapy in American school so I
mean what I do with my clients I just
write them a letter to take to their
to their generated GP
so you'll know you'll you'll learn what
the basic antidepressants are and
those will be the drugs you use most
often that you recommend most often
because they're they're broadly
effective for most conditions that
involve excess negative emotion now and
then
somebody will need an antipsychotic but
if you're a clinical psychologist with a
private practice that will happen very
often
so
medical school is a long haul
so if you're interested primarily in
working with people in a problem-solving
capacity
it could be the clinical psychologies of
their choice but you know you might be
medically oriented lots of people are
medically oriented if
if the more
if the more physiological element of
care appeals to you that medical school
is a good option some people do both
I don't know about that that's but you
know some people do both
your invited that it was like starting
University or like what you think of the
first years should be focusing on you
mean for first year graduate school uh
first year undergraduate
well what you should really do in your
first year as an undergraduate is you
should you should you should take a wide
variety of courses
you should sort of find out what you
might be interested in and you should
learn to learn to work
and learn to socialize
because those things are you know the
things that make people successful so I
talk about two of them right
intelligence conscientiousness that's
discipline creativity is another one but
that's pretty hard to develop if you
don't already have it but the fourth
thing that makes people
across time is breadth of social network
and so learning to socialize and to
develop a large connection with a large
social connection that's unbelievably
useful so you should get good at those
when you're in your first year you know
and that's that's pretty so if you come
out of your first year you're still in
University you got you know five courses
under your belt you've done decently you
have a circle of friends sort of start
to establish what you might be
interested in good and I was successful
you think is the time that you ought to
decide what you want
well the first thing I would say is it's
always better to do something than
nothing
so don't wait around
and what I mean by that practically is
if you're not sure what to do take a
guess and do that and do it hard and as
you do it you'll learn what's good about
it and what isn't and then somewhere
down the road six months you'll be in a
better position to figure out what you
want if you keep doing that sooner or
later you'll figure out exactly what you
want but don't wait around waiting is
you don't learn anything when you're in
limbo way so it's better to go off and
try things and and to try them hard
because then you actually inform
yourself and other than that there's no
real rule it takes people
you know
it takes people of varying amounts of
time to establish an identity if you
don't have a well-catalyzed identity by
the time you're
30 you're starting to it's starting to
not be good
and if it's really not there are still
by 40.
that's really not so good so if you're
confused get some
credentials
you want to have something to show for
your effort
but if you pay attention and you focus
and you work or you'll figure out what
you want
but but as I said before the best thing
to do to begin with is
you've got us see
you may not know this but the schools
that you attended before you went to
University they were established their
basic structure was established in the
late 1800s
and they were originally set up to teach
the children of factory workers to be
Factory workers they're factories you
can tell just by looking at them
even this to some degree is still a
factor it's the wrong model
the problem with factories is you're not
going to work in a bloody Factory
you're going to have a career
and to have a career you have to figure
out who you want to be
and so one of the things you want to be
doing over the next while is getting
this is why a liberal arts education is
so useful because the liberal arts
education helps teach you what a person
could be
and that's not the same as getting a job
and the university is not for getting a
job the university is for figuring out
what sort of person you could be
and so it's also useful to take
philosophy courses and to take
literature courses and to broaden
yourself so that you get a a better idea
of what the difference is between a
great person and a trivial person and I
mean that's not a very modern idea
because we like to think that all people
are the same and that's that's if all
people are the same you might as well
just stop doing what you're doing right
now because you're the as the same as
you're ever going to get
if there's differences in quality then
you should aim for what's high in
quality and then but you should also
know what that is and so in your first
year you know it helps to
to do some thinking and to be guided by
people who the culture recognizes as
great thinkers because they've thought
about what it means to be human and why
that matters and then you might as well
aim as high as you can aim
that'd be a good thing to start sorting
out the first couple of games University
so
um graduate programs I'm not sure I
should go straight for our PhD where I'd
offer our masters along the way it
doesn't matter Masters are useless
fundamentally I mean for for
most places for clinical most places you
can't practice with a master's degree
anymore and most clinical programs have
scrapped the Masters I think you can
still practice in Alberta and Quebec but
I'm not even sure about that anymore
for an academic career generally I mean
it depends on why you want to take the
extra education you know like
if you're going to go into business or
something like that a master's degree
might help you with that might
discipline you but if you're after the
academic career it's the PHD that is
that's the degree that you want and then
it probably doesn't really matter
whether you take the program that has a
master's mph
foreign
about those sorts of things so I mean as
long as you can practice with the
Master's Degree then that's no problem
and if you know
that that's a different career path I
mean that'll sometimes put you in as a
school counselor or something like that
and I mean that's a perfectly fine
occupational Choice it's uh I would say
in some ways it's a it's a more defined
and less demanding life and and that can
be
that can be extremely useful you know
what an academic career or something or
a career like that it's very in
it's kind of all consuming and that
isn't necessarily for everyone it
certainly isn't for everyone and it
should and it shouldn't be for everyone
you have to be compelled in that
direction for it to be the important
choice
if you want to
know
I know you'd have to be more specific in
the question I don't know exactly what
you're asking but if you wanted to
see the United States but
ultimately work in Ontario and yeah the
best your best bet is to contact the
college
and find out what their registration
numbers are
good luck with that
because their registration rules are
pretty vague and it's hard to pin them
down but that is what you should do to
protect yourself and you should get it
in writing
because on the phone that that's nothing
you need to get it right and I can't
really I can't really give you any more
specific information than us
um
I can't tell you a lot about them
because I like beside the oh the whole
side of these dream is outside of the
academic street they're professional
Schools they're mostly set up in the U.S
they take large number of students being
the acceptance criteria much lower but
the price you pay for that is the
incredibly High tuition it'll You'll
Rock up a two hundred thousand dollar
Gap now that might be okay you might be
able to pay that off because if being
included clinician can be relatively
lucrative the typical hourly rate is
maybe for us beginners maybe to get your
practice going would be perhaps 100 to
125 dollars an hour
and then that can go all the way up to
maybe 300 an hour although that's
uncommon 175 is probably more typical
and so if you see six clients a day
let's say five that's a thousand dollars
a day so it's about 250 000 a year and
so you can pay off a two hundred
thousand dollar debt pretty fast if you
you know if you if you set up a
successful clinical career afterwards
and there is quite a demand for clinical
psychologists there's no glot on the
market although people have to pay you
privately or through their insurance
companies because it's not an old
service
and um clinical psych programs that are
sort of like less recent performance we
said that they were at universities that
tend to give us
yeah well there's only about 40 large
research institutions in North America
and you can find them on the web they're
the ones you already may know about and
that there's a sprinkling of smaller
institutions and you know their emphasis
on Research productivity is a lot less
they're not they're not as competitive
so you can attend those places and get a
decent training as a scientific thinker
at the same time that you acquire your
clinical license it's perfectly
reasonable thing to do
so that's why at the beginning I said
you know apply broadly because
there's a big difference there's some
difference between universities and the
differences are trivial but there is a
massive difference between we have a
university and not being our own at all
so if you have the
privilege of being able to choose which
university you're going to go to well
great but you don't want to sacrifice
the binary Choice the positive binary
choice just to
you know fiddle around with the dial
okay so I'm going to close up so I'm
just going to give you a very quick
overly so here's what you can do
the psychologist
if you're not if you're an experimental
psychologist
generally you're heading for an academic
career however there are
opportunities in research Enterprises
outside of that
so in businesses for example
also the academic market for
psychologists is really opening up
because psychologists are increasingly
being hired in economics departments and
at Business Schools and as a junior
professor
at a psych department will start with
the selling 180 000 but at the business
school they'll start with the selling
book 250.
so and business schools are hiring
psychologists because they're figuring
out that we know what we're talking
about whereas business phds and
economists tend not to and that's
usually because their models of human
beings are wrong and they don't know
their statistics very well so anyways
the academic opportunities for
experimental PhD are expanding so it's a
good time to be a psychologist so it's
relatively hard to get in and when
you're in you better be productive
because you won't be a credible
candidate if you're not so you've got to
get disciplined on the clinical side
there's almost nothing more valuable as
a clinical degree
is you can work as a clinician
can work in a hospital
you can work in Academia and you can
work as a consultant
or you can do any combination of those
things so it's you have a vast range of
possibilities open up for you if you
have a clinical PhD it takes a long time
it's a six year PhD and then there's two
years of training after that and it's
hard to get in and when you're in it's
competitive then you have to work but if
you can pull it off
it sets you up for a vast range of
possibilities in your future
now and then
to conclude that personally if you want
to set yourself up for this sort of
thing
learn not to waste time
because that's the one thing you can do
that's sort of under your control that
will make you more competitive and start
to think about them think hard about how
you want your life to be and how you
don't want it to be because that can
increase your motivation to to do things
properly so
I'll take I guess in if there's another
question that you don't need that then
we should probably stop so does anybody
have a question that hasn't been
addressed yet
do you have a psychologist they can be
hard to sort of uh leave cases behind
you no
it doesn't here's what you have to
realize
it's not your suffering you have your
own suffering
your client is entitled to their
suffering it's part of their life
adding your own misery to theirs is not
going to help them all it does is muddle
up your thinking and it encroaches on
their territory
you're not there to take on their burden
you're there to help them attain Clarity
to figure out how to live properly and
so it's your you have an ethical it's
ethically required of you you stay
detached enough so that you're not
damaged by the encounter
and you'll learn to do that everybody
learns to do that in graduate school
you'd be surprised like because again
it's a perfectly valid question and
everybody wonders about it but
you learn how to do that and it's the
not only do you learn that it's the
right thing to do
so
one more question
of undergraduate so
um how do you know if they're doing that
today you don't so even if they specify
we only look at you last year this has
only started happening in the last
couple of years like I had a student
last year an excellent two years and she
didn't get in anywhere and it was she
found out that it was because they
looked earlier she had a pretty bad two
year early two years which as far as I'm
concerned is irrelevant hopefully she'll
solve that by applying to more places
but as the number of applicants grow
then the reason you know the methods by
which people will be dispensed with get
more General I don't think it's
reasonable but that's irrelevant
reasonable has nothing to do with it but
your best bet is just like I said is to
apply to more places so and you know
generally if you're
a or a minus 80 80th percent Algeria
reason above your credible candidate you
get it hard enough you'll probably find
a place to go thank you in the last two
years yeah in the last two years yeah
so that's still the rule of fun all
right well that's that so
we'll start please
thank you so much yeah thank you
oh I have one more thing suggesting
people
you may or may not know this but the
faculty the student The Faculty
nationwide at the University of grovel
on the St George campus is 451.
that is outrageous and you guys put up
there
and so one of the things you might
consider doing is not putting up with it
so much some letters to the dean about
the fact that there are 450 of you to
each faculty member funny van tuition
five grand seven seven Okay so
times 7 000.
so you pay three million dollars in
tuition for each professor and they have
a salary of maybe 150
000 that's a requirements if you don't
have to overhead is 300 000 you paid ten
times as much as you should per faculty
seller you're getting screwed and the
reason you're getting screwed is because
you put up with it and it's really not
good because one of the things that
would help you progress through your
academic career as a psychologist
property is if you could actually get
access to a professor now and then and
talk about things
so I would highly recommend if you do
this with the PSA
do something about it you're getting
ripped off there's no excuse for it
hundreds of one is appalling
that's 50 to one is decent
450 to one you're subsidizing the whole
flooding University and there's no
excuse for it and it doesn't bother me
because what I do about is I just don't
talk to students right because I have a
certain amount of time and I'll talk to
as many students as I can and pass that
I can talk to students because I can't
so it isn't bothering me except that
before it was needed it's happening to
you but you should do something about it
because there's no excuse for it and
unless you push on the University they
will not move so you're paying 3 million
bucks per Professor it's just higher
three million dollars worth of
professors but it's not good it's like
it's the worst faculty student to
faculty ratio of any department at the
University of Toronto
by a huge margin and among psychology
departments across North America it's
about the worst so
so you should do something about it
because yeah
hi
um
God you're going to have a rough
contract with you now because I'm
basically going now
um have you talked to Shelly person I
have